oh ok welcome to session number two
we're going to start looking now into
some of the fundamental data structures
that are used by the program and it to
start out I'd like to to just give some
idea as to how these 1200 modules of
tech can be representing me broken down
so let's see we could this is a little
diagram that I try to to estimate the
relative sizes if you had if you look
inside a memory and took out all the
system routines that were needed for
running Pascal programs and stuff and so
on what what tech would would involve
now the parts here between ok these
lines here this is code and then these
on the outside our tables of large
tables of data and the so the program
itself has 1,200 miles of opportunities
roughly 1,200 modules and I just counted
modules and i'm assuming about 100 bytes
per module on advice of code for every
module in the web thing that's the
estimate that I made so 10 modules would
be 1k bites and that's one square on
here so if it's so if I'd say that like
looked like about 1440 of those modules
we're concerned with syntax and that
would that the counts for this charge I
also tried in this chart to indicate
something about how the the parts of the
program talked to each other although it
could reflect all the all the
constraints you get some feeling for the
for the organization of the program by
this diagram so I'll go through a little
bit there's three kinds of input files
get read there's the text the users
source file on the tech
text input then is the font information
which comes in which is here and then
there's the initialization which is your
format file comes in with the very
beginning when when tech is loaded these
are three different kinds of files this
one would be a Pascal text file just
characters this one is a TFM file this
one is an FMT file format file the TFM
file is in 8-bit bites the fmt file is
in memory words which is a tech internal
data structure we would never expect to
to send FMT files from one computer to
another these are these are local things
that we'd keep only in the in someone's
on a local library and in any text
writes these files other versions of
tech read these five now the the the the
part of tech that that we call its eyes
and mouth is consider is the part that
reads in of the users text file and it
also has the macros that it that it
looks at when it for things that have
already been defined the fmt file of
course feeds into macros and the syntax
part is supposed to make some sense out
of these and keep track of what levels
of input that were in so that we might
be reading one file and then that file
said column at grow and that macro said
had some parameter and we're actually
looking at that parameter of the macro
and in that parameter it said input
another file and various levels can be
going on on at once so the 60 remember
these boxes of tech I'm indicating just
here not the size of the of the data but
the size of the program so this is the
amount of program i have here to deal
with macros reading and ND click
defining macros this is how much program
i have four
inputting text from files roughly
speaking and this includes from the
terminal so this includes things like
responding to error messages and so but
it doesn't indicate the size of the
buffers the size of buffer is only about
a half a que for input you could make it
larger if you wanted to but it's trivial
with respect to the side of the program
in that case how the alignment is
sitting in here too there's some program
for alignment I said this was the
hypnotic suggestion type of thing in
this it sits in the background and
contributes to the syntax now again then
locals program to deal with local
variables this is the grouping aspect of
tech that's thing they're supposed to go
away when right braces are hit and and
we have to save and restore think
equivalence the table of local things is
called the equivalence table and this is
it this is data here this is area where
we actually are storing all of the
counts of dimensions skips the values of
baseline skip all the parameters the
codes and all envy I also for every
control sequence of a pointer to where
it's defined now after we've read in
things then it's also text out this can
be either at a terminal for for Erica
for rum for error messages it could be
to the tour to the transcript file or to
ascend file and these and so some
program has to be there for dealing with
text output and it's about 40 modules
worth so that's four of these squares
now semantics is generally what we're
doing to digest this information after
we've eaten it and and the big part of
the semantics is concerned with math is
what formatting this is everything else
and besides math and this is matt so
listen tree parts for things that that
do we when you say H box or something
like that dealing with constructing of
boxes tub doing proper things with blue
some of the parsing though will be in
the syntax for example if you say H skip
five points in the syntax we consider
the thing that that recognizes five PT
and converts that to a number that the
semantics will deal with so then in the
math mode routines these are the things
that that will build em lists instead of
semantics or other smacks build ageless
and V list endless are the math this H
and V are horizontal and vertical list
now all the programs that deal with the
dynamic memory are this is where most of
tech is is stored and and so we have to
allocate things in this dynamic memory
and that in the first lecture in the
afternoon we'll be talking about the
dynamic memory to fermanagh kotas is to
vote to that including the one I
mentioned the last lecture where it's a
display box be because one of the things
you do with the dynamic memory is show
what's in it then sort of separate from
all that is the is are the optimization
routines that that come into action
after you've gathered together a list
and then then we try to break the list
in the best way into into lines of pages
so there's a paragraph there there's a
lot of code devoted to finding the best
way to break paragraphs and that code or
occasionally talks to the hyphenation
part of the tech but the hyphenation
doesn't really talk directly to any
other module just the paragraph or if
paragraph or gets stuck it calls
hyphenated and the paragraph who puts
things back in the memory and and
asynchronously whenever there's enough
gathered to do something to for output
then the page builder comes along and
and send something else then the the
program that actually does the output to
the DVI file is a little it's not very
long in fact most of these modules are
comments about what DVI files to what
DVR
and there's program that reads in font
information so now the hyphenation
tables take up certain amount of space
and the equivalence table takes up about
the same amount of space for all the
registers we have more space indicated
here for font information and a little
bit less for all the strings in and
we're going to talk mostly this hour
about strings to help you add all this
up and see how many kbytes is it it's
very encouraging because it comes out to
be from like 260 k or something like
that however I left out one one small
detail and that if there's another table
which is the whole dynamic memory which
I haven't shown on here because
everybody talks to that practically and
you can think of that as an overlay
about equal in size or or or maybe half
the size so to get the dynamic memory I
would put it I would give I would say
you need a hundred K of dynamic memory
to do about to do a fair amount of
typesetting and the and with the 300 k
it'll be it would be now 256k is as much
as as you'll be able to get on some
machines with 16 to the dresses because
we we address them four bytes at a time
so somewhere in between there you'll get
the total size of tech I've made these
other tables of reasonable for for a
fairly large scale production so I would
say that oh you're your tech would then
add up to something between 350 and six
hundred thousand bytes plus the amount
for a Pascal runtime system depending on
how sold so half a megabyte it looks
like you should you have a chance of
doing good types thing but you'd be
comfortable with this little more than
that any questions on this
I hope this picture helps to give a
little bit more perspective as to what
we're going to be dealing with inside so
you're you're this is a ten by twelve
area from in here which covers the 1200
modules in the tech Jimmy tech writing
and the number of those modules devoted
to different parts of tech is sort of
indicated by the sizes of those
rectangles oh by the way I forgot to
mention there's little microphones in
front of your eyes and you pick that up
and push the red button and everyone can
hear on the tape how does that memory
requirement compare with tech eighty can
do you know and no in Yaqui can you how
can you say
what about the dynamic memory decides
what to say okay
I think the program has gotten a little
small or x bought the same so what the
spring memory is new well I don't know
no it isn't really knew that things are
packed reasonably efficiently you you
can also use trickery to to decrease the
memory requirements of course but not
just plug in this this program you have
to you have to do some major changes to
some of the macros there's a ways to
fight here and there I tried to
emphasize readability over efficiency
without sacrificing efficiency two
months so yeah but it's roughly the same
I would say now the let's see the next
thing I want to do is is a next thing I
want to do is turn off the projector so
we can see the computer again I wanted
to show you the pool file that tangle
type dog protect we're going to be
talking about strings and and one of the
things that Pascal is weak on is strings
the they provide certain certain kind of
support for strings but not very much
and and so in order to use Pascal as a
language we had to develop a mechanism
now this was originally the idea of I
think Lewis strappado Annunaki in the
other version of tech after they fought
with the problem of strings for one I
think they came up with a solution
that's not only good but has turned out
to have many other big payoffs that we
didn't expect so that now I'm very happy
that Pascal didn't have strings if I'd
used Pascal strings there have been a
lot of other things that wouldn't have
worked as well as things are working now
so we have a string method in tech that
also turned out to solve a lot of other
problems in a better way than then we
had than otherwise would have occurred
nice and as we get more into it I think
you'll understand what I'm what I mean
but first of all let's see what tangled
us to two strings so if the machine is
still up we can take a look at tech dot
can you see this on that screen there is
coming up awesome ok now the pool file
that's written out by tango is it
consists of lines again our maximum
length of a 72 characters because the
the restriction on the length of strings
that you can use in weave and each line
comes out at each string comes out on a
line by itself so that means carriage
return line feed or if somebody has a
IBM machine that means that that that
there's a lot of blanks or nulls at the
end now the the first two characters our
line is the length of the string itself
so the first string that people
currently appears in this program is
buffer size and it's 11 characters long
and and so on you get to see all of the
all of the strings if you if you push
through this file and it's eight hundred
and eighty ninety eight lines long
actually the last line is not a string
the last one is special it's a it's
called the string pool some check now
tango has this extra the special number
with an asterisk in front of it at the
end of the file with a following idea
that if you have changed any one of the
strings in the inner program then
chances are very good at this number
will be different and you can also refer
to this number in your web program and
say what is my string fool number
therefore you can find out if you've
read in the string pool that sneaked
that's yours because you can look and
see if your a string pool number equals
this one at the end of the file now if I
edit this if I edit this tech pool file
it without changing a number at the
bottom
program won't complain you're not
supposed to touch this this file
yourself this file is supposed to be
made by tango but you see it this is
important because if you were started to
load a file that was that was generated
without the right you know somebody
suddenly put another string in his
change file or something like that and
and the strings get out of sync then you
get very interesting printouts from tech
where we have some permutation of all
the strings coming out one point it says
prints doing a hundred it actually print
something quite different and it might
be amusing to some people but
frustrating to other okay so that last
thing in the file is your is the
streamflow checksum now this file isn't
that isn't that mnemonic to read because
it doesn't tell you what string number
in is and and so there's a trivial
program at the beginning of the tech
where report that handout that you got
called pool type and the pool type
program does something is due to spring
pools and so will demonstrate that now I
think I've got it already compiled it's
such a trivial okay wait my son has a
message for me here
now okay so let's run full time pool
file will be checked at KU or poo an
output will be Ohio not cool okay so now
it's reading in that file and presumably
making the output file for it and we can
look at pooled up type to see we could
print this out of course to see what
what the strings are inside now the
first hundred twenty eight strings I
mentioned are special and that's right I
can this is these are not however the
pool type I've done was done with with
sale versions fool type so this has our
local character set i'll be talking with
mud characters that also in this hour
but let me make another let me do
another pool type without the sale
dependent changes so let's see i'll run
tango on pool type without any change
file and it doesn't have a pool of its
own so whenever you you run a web with a
boat's Donny seats isn't that great when
you have a short program it was 11
second instead of two minutes now the
pet now we're going to compile an and go
the and I'm making a version without the
change file my change file refers to my
local character set and the sale
character set has a keyboard that has
some symbols on it which I I like very
much
especially the unequal sign and the and
less than or equal sign Greek on the
left arrow I would find it very
difficult to have to write less than
greater than every time instead of
unequal that would be quite painful for
me so I'm glad I can do that here and I
imagine there are a few other people
that feel the same way so we try to make
tech that it will be able to be to allow
that for people at Stanford however we
want also so that it's not going to be
confusing that we can also send our
files to places elsewhere and not lose
the machine dependent so we have I think
a pretty good solution to that now
explain it my man versus look at pool
that temp cool that temp shows the
strings that we would get without sale
character set okay now the first hundred
and twenty eight strings so number 0 327
our our or what gets printed out for
asking for tech internal codes and so
starting at 32 we have ascii code 32 is
a space 33 ! 34 is is a double quote can
you see that ok on there i can't see it
on my mom yeah okay so and then we get
up to 126 which is a tilde and then then
the other codes aren't visible in ascii
and so for interchange purposes we are
representing them with two up arrows and
another symbol and for example 1 27
which would be ascii code octal 177
would it comes out at up arrow up arrow
? and at the beginning of the thing if
you remember we have the at sign and a
through capital A through a capital C
and then the next ASCII codes that
go in there so so this is a a form that
tech 82 will accept if you put it in
your input if you say I'll pero pero s
capital s a bear a bear capital s it
will treat it as the asking code that is
19 in decimal if we compare this to I'm
so it was cool that type we compared
that same thing to the sale character
set and see that it's sale some of these
we will assume that someone can type so
a down arrow will assume they can type
yeah that's rather handy for subscripts
and alpha beta and sign not at salon pi
lambda and then when we get to a symbol
nine there which is at which is octal
11s butt is that tab I think isn't it
yeah eight is back space sometimes but
nine is tab and so there if somebody
wants to so if we're printing out this
is these strings are using printing and
so for printing out a tab mark that
somebody that we might have read in at
sale then it would print out as up there
up arrow I if somebody inputs up air up
or I even at sailor anywhere it will go
in as internal code number nine okay and
these tab mark line feed vertical tab
carriage return and Paige mark form feed
our are not visible symbols so so we
would print them in that way and if
someone wants to define control sequence
backslash of barrow uh pero el that'll
work and it'll it'll be your back or he
wants to do a check code on that symbol
he can do it this way you can check old
your courage
turn to mean something and song now
these internal codes on the other one
would all be with all the UH perils and
so if I'm sending a file to some other
place I would use a version of tech that
would print every it would print in the
standard form and by making system
dependent changes you say what there's a
module called character k can be printed
and that that code is duplicated in the
pool type program and in the tech
listing module kick forgot to tell you
an important thing about how to read web
program that is that there's an index to
all the modules all the module names
after the other index and that's very
helpful if you are looking at something
in the web file I want to find out where
it is in the thing and I and as I
remember it was called character k can
be printed is the module that I'm
looking for here so on page 4 38 I found
character k cannot be printed is module
number 49 and so now I can look at
module number 49 and and there's a
comment there it's called true in the in
most versions of tech character k cannot
be printed is true in most versions of
tech namely this is for characters k
that are non ASCII codes non-visible
ascii code that's only supposed to work
for the for those values of Kahless and
then octo octa for t less than 32
decimal so I saying that this this is
true here now on the other hand at MIT I
suggest that it can't be printed be v 0
10 to 12 14 15 and 33 because the 33 is
an escape code and 14 is your carrot is
your line form feed and so on now so
then only a few characters cannot be
printed in that place now this is
assistant going to change
and in foreign countries there will be
different ideas on what to do with these
codes less than 40 so question vector is
what does it mean so what so well what's
the giving in to these internal codes
have well in a way if you changed your
codes to have something to anything else
it wouldn't matter that much to tech we
would still compile still compile
programs except that these numbers are
used in the language in in several ways
first of all the internal numbers the
tech has go out into your DVI file in
the font like if you happen to say
letter a in in a certain font then that
then the internal code that Tech has for
a is what gets used as the character
number in in your DVI file so it'll say
it'll so you DVI file say you your maybe
in front number 63 and you're setting
character number 65 that's a capital A
or at least that's intex internal code
for capital a so so if the manufacturer
has that capital a in another position
in his font file it your output driver
makes the conversion at that point so we
have we have to have some kind of
standard internal code that everybody
uses and if you use an episodic or
something on your external files the
first thing tech does reading in a
program out of the outside world is
going to convert that to its internal
code so that also that the rest of tech
knows exactly what's what's going on and
guarantee that 0 through 9 are
consecutive numbers and things like that
now if you do something you know you can
convert any of your outside codes to any
internal cause you want
and and then then on the output we will
go back and and do the inverse operation
the the idea is that if you if you never
print out these codes that are not
standard in ascii then you can still do
it with the up there when i said uh pair
off error s is equivalent to one of
these asking control codes i should have
been a little more exact that it's not
just an up arrow any character whose
check code is a superscript mark is is
is the real thing that instead of what i
said up arrow so if up arrow hasn't been
Checotah to superscript mark then it
doesn't work and if but if any character
who has been chacorta 22 superscript
mark the two should be i should be
identical and both superscript mark but
they could be any but but otherwise I
tech will allow this on input in the
middle of a control sequence name if
that thing is to colon as a letter for
example it's possible to do that now
that the the other place where where
internal code is used in checotah
statements for example in text so you'll
say what's the check code of of
something and we have this this back
this reverse ' operator that converts a
character into tech and internal code
number so she code 65 sets the code for
uppercase a the reverse ' upper case a
is equal to 65 so this is a definite
part of a language of text language as
to what it does for the for its internal
code number I think some of you know
that sale the computer that we are that
we've got here has a strange code that
nobody else goes in the world because
that they started at Stanford with s key
code earlier than before ascii code was
even in its first form and one guy one
night figured he could save five
existence or something in the
in our machine by switching around the
coated right brace to one to the other
you did it overnight without telling
anybody in next and ever since we've had
right brace in the position different
from the rest of the world now we have a
few other characters that are that are
unusual to and certainly the burden
should not be on the rest of the world
but should be on us too to have to make
our change file a little harder than
yours you can or do that so text
internal character code is based on a
code that I that I think is the best
proposal for for representing these
extra characters as invisible way it's
the one that's used on several MIT
machines and so at MIT nope no
conversions are needed if you wanted to
use a recommended conventions for codes
less than octal 40 the strange ASCII
codes now most of you just won't want to
do anything with those characters and
you won't see them on your input files
and you won't have a right a money
output files but you could do you can
imagine people in in foreign countries
that want that have more than 26 letters
in their alphabet and they also want to
have backslash in a lot of and other
control characters to use I believe it
would be good idea to map those letters
for text purposes for tech purposes in
two codes less than 40 and and then they
can send their source files and
everything else to America and we'll
still be able to do to work with them as
if they were as if they were generated
here so the internal character set
represents the first these first cause
and then pool type just types out the
other ones with us with numbers
associated with them so that you can see
exactly if you're if you had a debug and
you wanted to really look at the Pascal
programming and Pascal program refers to
cut string number 432 then you could
look at the thing and say well 432 is
this is such and such a message so you
probably be able to i dint from what
that string was maybe a help message is
be able to recognize what what part of
the Pascal program you're looking at
that that pool type is simply a help in
that way to shoot so that you can figure
out what's in a what's in one of these
pool files that tangle generates any
questions on that now what actually
happens then when a when text starts it
has to read in the pool file so it reads
in this pool but only initech does this
any tech reason in the pool file and
checks to see that we've got the right
of some check and stores that all into
the format file with the rest of the
macros and find information that it's
going to preload on the other hand it
also stores the font some check so that
the other versions of tech they won't
check anything except with but except
they will check to see that they have
the right the format file was generated
from the right some check okay so so
other production versions of tech will
also know that their format file is
compatible with them they'll try to load
a format file that was generated with a
different version of tech and then the
strings won't be compatible and so it'll
it'll say right away or that this format
file is wrong how the the way strings
are represented inside of tech have a
big array called the string pool and
let's see where I can string handling is
starts in module 36 page 18 okay
the big there's a big array declared in
module 39 and and in this array you see
string pool packed array of ascii code
ascii code is a sub range of the integer
0 2 127 and only things that are going
to go in this string pool array are
visible character or characters that we
can print also so the the input routine
is set up so that I'm not going to put
in into that into that string pool
buffer any of the codes that would come
out with up arrow up there or something
in the printing out only only the ones
that I could print are going in there
and they're all seven bits up characters
nothing over 127 Wow if you look just
above that it says types in the outer
block 18 plus equivalent and it mentions
pool pointer I guess I should have
mentioned that the types when you have
the plus equivalent there and it refers
to module 18 but here we are in module
38 what we're saying here is that these
are more types in the outer block 18 was
the first module where we had types in
the outer block and if you turn to pick
to modulate een it tells you all the
other ones where they are so module 18
says see also sections 2538 that's only
at 96 and so on up to 812 and besides
thing where the code is used it says see
also this means that many modules with
the same name all get butted together in
the order in which they appear in the
program so this is one of the places
where we want a new type so when we
refer to something as a pool pointer
this will mean an index into the string
pool array and whenever we're talking
about the the swing pool array then
something that's going to go into stir
pool it'll have an index but if the type
will be pool pointer and similarly a
string number is something that that's a
string start array well the string start
array is a directory to the pool to the
pool and the strings that tech gets it
once it reads one in it never removes it
in unless it's the very last one ready
sometimes the last one ready and you
don't want to see anymore and you delete
that but we but it just operates in a
very simple fashion because that the
rules of tech it turned out that's what
you want so it starts out with all the
strings that these 800 and some strings
that tangle if we read that into the
string pool array and that then after
that we're going to have strings for
various other purposes and tech has
tickets going and they'll be continually
added at the end like file names of your
fonts and so on now the string start is
a pointer into into the array and so
that it tells you where that string
begins so stringing number 100 for
example will start at some place in the
unit pool array and at the very
beginning we're going to put in we're
going to put in those first hundred
twenty eight strings also even if
they're one character long we're going
to put them there now there's no string
end or a reason is that if you want to
know where string 100 ends you just look
at where spring 101 starts and it's one
because it you know and that's that's
where it is so uh so we don't need so we
only need the one array string start and
then we have to keep if we have n
strings in the spring pool we have n
plus 1 starting positions so that the
starting the start alpha of the of the
string we're going to do next is also
recorded there so that we can find the
end of the last string we had in so
that's all as to it as far as
representing strings is concerned and so
there's a macro defined therein module
for tea length of a string so if we want
to know how long string number K is we
just ask for its length which is the
difference between the two swing start
positions for modules 38 2 so on I just
build up very simple routines for for
dealing with strings that that other
of tech are going to use as subroutines
there's a simple one that flushes a
string the destroys the rose most
recently mainstream hence module 44
there's there's one is called string
room that's at the bottom of page 18 a
string room you call string room of five
for example to see if there's room for a
string of length 5 and so it says if
pool pointer plus five grid and pool
size then overflow pool size pool size
the first parameter to overflow is a
string saying is you're going to get in
here message saying sorry text memory
sticks capacity is exceeded in the pool
size equals and then it will give the
numerical size that it's been compiled
with and pool size is a compile-time
parameter and all the composite line
parameters I believe are in module 11
notoya module 11 input and ugly that we
that you can decide on at VP how much
space you one and here I declared it to
be 30,000 remember this gets this is a
packed array of seven bits on our 36-bit
computers that means we get five to a
word and 30,000 takes six thousand words
on on a better car by oriented machine
this would mean 35 30 k bytes in a row
and on a 32-bit word machine this would
of course before to a word and so on and
this number it says it must be at least
22,000 more than string vacancies and
string vacancies is another compile time
parameter and I set that to 8,000 now
why I put this 22,000 that's because
we're using almost 22,000 for the
strings in in tech already the error
messages and help messages and
everything I think at the end of the
pool type I might even have that
don't don't worry about oh yeah you've
got okay wait I gotta get all the way to
the end here last extension yeah twenty
1175 characters in all and so I'm just
rounded that up to 22,000 because people
will be adding extensions and things
like that to probably run up a little
bigger so this is a now what happens is
that when when it reads in the pool file
it makes sure that there's also room for
string vacancies more more otherwise I
in any tech will complain saying that
string that you got to increase pool
size so that's a compile-time parameter
depending on how many things that you're
going to do and it said it tells you
here in module 11 it says it's the
maximum number of characters and strings
including all error messages and health
texts also the names of all fonts names
of all control sequences these are the
kinds of things that go into the pool
you see it's names of names of control
sequences when you declare a control
sequence and it's not a one letter one
character control sequence if it stated
some multi letter control sequence the
name goes right into the string pool
here's one of the things I mentioned
before where I saying that this was this
method of dealing with strings was was
giving us advantages over what we had in
the sale version of tech because sale
version of tech we couldn't the
implementation of strings was quite
inefficient we didn't want to use sale
strings for control sequences or instead
though we had to go into our dynamic
memory and take away valuable space
therefore the names of control sequences
my first the original design of tech if
anybody remembers way back in 1977 I had
real strange restrictions that control
sequence had to consist of at most five
letters and an upper and lower case were
not distinguished after the first one
and things like this was all so that I
could keep a separate table of my
control sequences and I had the idea at
first that hardly anybody would be
defining new control sequences
I didn't realize that macros were going
to be very powerful at at first and so
then gradually we've found that people
actually want control sequences so we've
made grouper well now but treating on my
strings solve lots of problems with the
data structure because then I can I can
because I don't need a special program
for example to print out the name of a
control of a control sequence because
I've already got a program that prints
out a string and so that was one of the
one of the simple advantages that we
were able to combine to client two kinds
of data structures into one here now you
see there are subroutines there on
module 45 to compare a string to the
buffer this is what we would be doing
when we're looking up but to see if our
control sequences in a table or not
another one that compares two strings to
see if they're if they're equal to each
other that went weren't that's what we
want to do when we're loading fonts to
see if a fund has already been loaded
and then the next few sections are just
the things that come that are used to to
initialize the strings one point I could
point to show you at the page 21 my see
page 21 module 51 says I can't read tech
pull you notice that that's not that's a
Pascal string it has single quotes
around it not double quotes you can see
why because we couldn't read the spring
pool so we have to use Pascal strings
there well now in Pascal you can't call
a you can't use strings as an argument
to a function unless they're all there a
certain length that enough so you might
wonder how I could do this both that's
because bad pool of course is a macro
it's defined up up above there and it
writes this string and so again having
macros we're able to get around one of
the deficiencies of Pascal and it it
writes that error message saying i can't
read tech pull and dice it returns false
to the to the procedure itself so that
the
we'll give you another error message
there's a so these messages you have to
increase pool size depending on string
vacancies and so on are all done in this
case it also syntax checks the pool file
to see if it it's been collaborate or
not okay any questions on that I don't
see ya please use the mic kind of what
string a string begin with a constant a
string begins with a double quote and
ends with a double quote and anything
goes in between yeah it's okay anything
goes in between tonight so so any any
text whatsoever if you have double
quotes inside you you have to have have
quadruple quotes you have to double them
again so that a double quote inside of a
string gets gets doubled in question
there you said that the shrink was used
for macro name there whether it build
garbage collection of mine macro name
there's no if it turns out an intact
that you really find that a if you
define a control sequence undefined
control sequences happens only at the
end of the group then it's it's very
difficult to tell whether that control
sequence is really not going to be used
again because another control sequence
might have used it and been declared
global and so in order to so there is no
garbage collection the the number of
times that that would actually have
saved memory was much was actually less
than the amount of memory we would have
saved by not having the code for garbage
collection so so this is why there's no
garbage collection
okay so the next section talks about
online and offline printing and here's
where we get to use the string pool to
just print messages and so the I'll talk
a little bit about the printing routines
these again are very basic to the whole
process I think these are the ones that
actually get declared first there's a
procedure called initializing and as a
procedure in the basic printing
procedures and they start in module 56
the first one is a print print line
procedure now the interesting thing here
is that the printing procedure there's a
destination for printing so that when my
program says print it might write on a
terminal it might write on the honor the
errors transcript file that you get
after you run tech might do both it
might be writing on in one of the send
files it might be writing into the
string pool itself and so you can change
the destination so that also that all
you need is a few print procedures and
whenever you say print integer that will
send an integer to the proper
destination with that destination might
be a variety of different things you
still don't need a different sub routine
for each one okay so by switching the
destination we're able to get by with
just a few know all our procedures are
called print but what actually happens
to it one of the destinations is no
print which means it just disappears
okay there's one called pseudo which is
number 20 these are all defined on page
22 module 54 this one called pseudo
which is used in an interesting way for
showing that the context of your error
lines you know when you can error
message from tech it tries to show you
where it was and it gives a two-line
indication of this the first line shows
the characters Tech has read so far
second line shows the things that hasn't
even seen yet and this might be in the
middle of a huge macro definition for
example and so the macro might be a
hundred thousand bytes long when it
expands
or very long anyway now because when
we're expanding it we're expanding all
the control sequence names off to their
full length and so on now we don't want
to have a special buffer that expands
out a hundred thousand vice and then and
then shows the 60 that were actually
interested in so instead we keep a
buffer of size 60 and we go circularly
around and around in this buffer that's
what pseudo printing is and then when it
stops it has enough information when to
just print out the characters you need
it in the environment the buffers a
little more than 60 but it's just not
small amount so this is a method so slow
printing is turned on when you're just
when you have a little bit of of when
you're using this trick of what were you
going to run you're going to print a
whole bunch of stuff and then you're
only going to select a little bit out of
it and what you do is you turn off of
storing into the buffer after you've
gotten past your your your key point so
so let's say the buffers of length 60
and that is the transition between line
1 and line two occurs at a certain point
at this time you're going to you're
going to write at most 30 or 40 more
characters before you quit and then
you're going to shut off grinning so
that's the pseudo thing which is
explained elsewhere now no that's so so
by having these print procedures we can
change that but they're all called print
and many maintenance one of the most
frequently used things in tech will say
print an integer and this side
automatically does binary decimal
conversion and but you can send the
image or anywhere you want like to a
string so if somebody wants to see a
string but stored as a string you can do
that by setting the selector to new
string and then you get a new springing
of the string pool so this is a another
turn out to be another advantage of
having the data structures organized
this way instead of help instead of
making use of of a particular string
feature that might have been in in in
Pascal so I like what I guess I'm saying
is that that by programming my strings
homemade I have much more
I had more flexibility on what i could
do with them in an efficient way I
didn't have to to worry I didn't have to
consider a very inefficient but highly
general methods that as some assistant
programmer would put in for a string
package that would have a lot of
overhead take a lot more memory space
besides making the program a lot more
portable and and not really longer so so
this home-baked approach the strings has
not been a it turned out this week one
of the first things they struggled with
using Pascal turned out afterwards or
the blessing in the sky the print
procedure on page 24 module 58 is the
thing that we use to print out a string
so just to reinforce what I've said this
hour i'm getting near the end of the
hour let's just look at that print
procedure and see well it says this is
uh is so simple it doesn't even call
anything else but just it should
reinforce what we're talking about so
procedure print s is integer print
string s now this is something i changed
last week as i was debugging s used to
be called the type street store number
like print new line s is astir number
and this is Prince string at the
beginning of a line it's the same as
print except for the making sure that it
goes at the beginning of a line but but
here I said s could be any integer
anybody have an idea why that why I had
to make that change well I decided to
make that change the reason is a while
I'm debugging I have made my bugging
routines extremely robust so that if
memory has gotten completely clobbered
is still allowed to look at any location
in memory and say if this is a pointer
to a string printed and so it should be
it shouldn't give and and if memory did
get clobbered then at least I would have
some my symbolic indication which part
of it would make sense in the cloud part
would would would be there but it
wouldn't the program wouldn't die on me
well if I didn't say this was an integer
Pascal
stop me saying that parameter to print
is not in there in the range of a string
number so I change this to an integer
and then we have a test inside the
program that says if s is less than 0 or
greater or equal string pointer then set
s 20 this can't happen well it can't
happen in lists of buggies is a present
of course nothing everything can happen
in a computer if you see if there's
above and I don't call an error message
if s is less than 0 or x greater than 0
remember I said before print programs
aren't supposed to I'm supposed to call
error messages otherwise error would
call print and print and call error and
you can you go on and on forever so it
just sets it s 20 which is going to
print out a very unusual string one that
you string number 0 is this up arrow up
arrow at sign when you see that that's a
good an error message enough ok so then
J is set to stir start of s that's where
it that's jay is now of type pool
pointer that means it's an index into
the buffer and I'm assuming that stir
start is not clobbered but but the s
itself might have been clobbered now
while j is less than the string start of
the next string s plus 1 that's always
defined when string s is less than
string pointer and greater than 0 then
the skirt start s plus 1 is defined
that's where the next one starts so
while at j is less than that i print
char string pool j print char is the
lower level procedure that just takes
the character right out of the buffer
and sends it out to paske increase j and
continue that that Prince the thing so
that's why I that's what the Prince char
procedure doesn't look for string number
you know print char 65 doesn't look for
spring number 65 print char Prince char
Betsy text internal character code 65 at
the end so that the stir pool entries
must all be printable characters let's
look at print char
all of the print procedures I said you
could change the destination every print
procedure works through print left print
line and print char these are in and
they all reduced to these so these are
the only two that look at the selector
that looked i look at the ethic as the
Prince elector and do n so you could go
if you want to deflect it you just
deflected in these two places and print
jar takes an ascii code as a parameter
and and so for example it's both were
writing on the terminal only that would
be term only case and it would say right
term out extra of C now exter is the
array that is set up to convert from tex
internal code to episodic or whatever
and that's where you want to make system
dependent changes so let's look at where
extra is set up that song starts on page
10 and a section called the character
set and the things i mentioned about
characters that are discussed there on
page 10 on page 11 you see where extra
is set up a whole bunch of assignment
statements these are supposedly not
system dependent if we assume that your
pascal can read any of the visible ASCII
codes then it you don't need any changes
here otherwise you do but this these
assignment statements will set extra of
octal 42 of the the character blank and
so on and many many implementations of
pascal will then set extra properly by
this but by the statements it and it
then on the other on the other codes
less than an octal 40 that's explained
on the next page on page 12 and there's
a and the standard version of tech that
hasn't been modified in module 23 the
standard version of down here is says
just blank it out said said all these
other characters that you don't expect
to find on the input to blank and then I
you know if you are able to output them
the output
blanks also but at MIT I suggested that
you could just set them all to the
character itself because text internal
code agrees with this MIT code so that
that's a system dependent change that of
course would have to be made if you want
to do something special with the codes
under 40 however most installations
won't have to do anything with those I I
guess all right that's all except if
there are questions any more question I
can offer you a tempting lunch if you
don't ask me any questions okay good
that I work so we'll meet again here at
two what is it two o'clock sharp thanks
you